après la stupeur qui succède à une
catastrophe naturelle
le temps est à la reconstruction et pour
cela il faut pouvoir compter sur le
tissu économique de son pays
améliorer la capacité de résistance des
entreprises c'est le but du bureau des
nations unies pour la réduction des
risques de catastrophes à travers cette
formation
chacun peut aussi partager son
expérience comme ces professionnels
haïtiens de l'humanité malheureusement
les entreprises du secteur privé avait
fait d'europe aussi afin de pouvoir
donner une réponse lui aussi ce serait
beaucoup plus profitable pour l'économie
du pays en général si on aurait eu des
aides humanitaires qui pourrait aussi
acheter du secteur privé et la
distribution pour aider les entreprises
à faire face aux risques climatiques
l'onu dispense cette formation une
vingtaine de professionnels de toute la
caraïbe
dominique haïti martinique l'objectif
anticiper pour mieux assurer la
continuité de l'activité économique des
catastrophes d'apprendre les très
petites et petites entreprises sont
particulièrement vulnérables
or elles composent la majorité de
l'activité économique dans la caraïbe
leur défi protéger les ressources
humaines et matérielles
en cas de séisme ou duras dans un pays
il ne récupère rapidement quand
l'activité économique reprend rapidement
parce que c'est elle qui va nourrir des
familles celle qui va créer de
l'activité et puis celle qui va aussi
redonner un peu de vie à la population
qu'elle ne tombe pas dans une histoire
une espèce de dépression ces
professionnels diffuseront ces
connaissances à leur tour chez eux pour
renforcer la capacité de résilience de
leur entreprise pour mieux se relever
après le drame